mein thema heute abend ist armin laschet
und seinem satz als 4 ist kein beruf für
mich ist es der satz der woche weil er
wichtig ist natürlich gab es großes
ärgernis vor allem bei den linken
parteien wie man sowas sagen könnte aber
es ist wahr hartz4 ist kein beruf wenn
man sollte nun die bürger auch nicht vom
staat langfristig abhängig machen lassen
wie kam es denn überhaupt zu dem satz es
gab es kann z rihanna berbalk gesagt hat
sie wieder die regelsätze ab scheiße wir
die erhöhen die regelsätze und die
sanktionen abschaffung für hartz4 das
heißt das prinzip fordern und fördern
wäre außer kraft gesetzt regelsätze für
als wir nach oben keine sanktionen hat
hier wird einfach ausbezahlt das ist
falsch ich persönlich finde es falsch
dass die grünen und die spd möchte das
auch dass die sanktionen abgeschafft
werden und die regelsätze angehoben
werden damit wohl machen diese partie
eigentlich die menschen im sozialsystem
vor allem weil auch experten sagen dass
die sanktionen helfen weil sie auch
anreize sind einen neuen job zu suchen
und zu finden
also ich fand er diesen satz in diesem
dritten satz des abends ja hartz4 ist
kein beruf
weil er ausdrückt das ist eine
übergangssituation sein sollte eine ein
jahr nothilfe aber doch kein
dauerzustand und ich glaube er
hat auch klar zum ausdruck gebracht dass
wir hier in einem system leben
das manchmal wohlstand suggeriert das
halte ich für ganz gefährdet die
illusion dass der staat
leistungslosen wohlstand
garantiert diese staatlichen garantien
sind dann für alle die wirklich was
leisten wollen eine die motivation und
einer der dann in diesem hartz4 system
quasi lebt der muss sich auch
vergleichen lassen mit denen die dafür
arbeiten denn er wird doch bezahlt durch
die steuernde anderen hat dann wird vom
geld bei anderen bezahlt und das ist
solidarität die reale hier begrüßen aber
solidarität muss in zwei richtungen
gehen nämlich zum einen ihr wollt die
starken helfen den schwächeren aber das
schwächere muss sich in zeigen im rahmen
seiner möglichkeiten anstrengen wasser
vielleicht aus dem schlamassel wieder
raus findet und seine sein leben selbst
gestalten kann und nicht von den anderen
unterhalten dann muss da sind der
solidarität ist auch ein wichtiger punkt
war ich kannte auch dieses hat hier ist
kein beruf es gibt ja viele aufstocker
in deutschland komplett vollzeit
arbeiten dann auch zum start gehen und
aufstocken müssen gut finde ich das
nicht ist aber die realität und was wäre
dann wenn andere einfach ohne sanktionen
geld ausgezahlt bekommen es war auch ein
punkt der mich er gestern gesagt hat
also im einsatz elektrisiert dass er im
dritten und die perspektive im wahlkampf
mal verschoben hat im wahlkampf wurde
eigentlich nur darüber geredet wie
verteilen wir das potenzial projekt mit
mindestlohn und umverteilung und
investitionen in mehr klimaschutz und
ähnliche dinge und dieser satz eröffnete
so ein bisschen das fenster ihn wie er
wirtschaft eigentlich das
bruttosozialprodukt als er zwei
verschiedene denkwelten und wir waren
viel zu sehr in einer welt und er hat
der laschet endlich mal einen
rausgehauen hätten wir ja gar nicht mehr
zugetraut
und für mich ist das verblüffende dass
er auf der zielgeraden tatsächlich in
form kommt jetzt haben wir heute neue
umfragen gekommen und wenn man die jetzt
mal mathematisch umbrechen der war bei
19 prozent vor einer woche bei 22 das
sind zwei millionen wähler also zwei
millionen wähler hatte in einer woche
dazu gewonnen jetzt nicht unbedingt mit
dem satz aber es ist offen
also als ich dann mein abitur gemacht
hat mein vater zu mir gesagt so wenn du
später gutes leben haben willst musst du
was leisten also erstmal vierten klasse
die erste vier in mathe dann hatte gab
es richtig ärger zu hause ich fand das
leistungsprinzip bei mir zu hause mal
gut und ich glaube schon dass es viele
auch schon imponiert er das lasche dass
endlich mal wieder erwähnt hat weil man
hat ja recht es ging ja eigentlich nur
noch um umverteilung und es ging ja gar
nicht mehr darum wie schaffen wir sind
auch menschen anzureizen zu träumen noch
besser wäre es allerdings gewesen wenn
nicht nur die überschrift geliefert
hätte sondern die auch noch mit ein
bisschen
bekenntnis zu der idee die in der
umtreibt versehen hätte denn das ist
doch eigentlich das was aufeinander
trifft die einen sagen das sind menschen
in not den müssen wir helfen egal wie
sie sich verhalten ob sie sich bemühen
sie sich nicht bemühen das ist unser
sozialstaat pflicht denen zu helfen das
ist ja erstmal ein sehr aus dem herzen
kommen das argument oder und es ist auch
nicht bringen aber jetzt muss man ja in
allein damit ist ist laschet wir mit dem
satz schon ein bisschen in der defensive
und jetzt hätte er finde ich noch
deutlich machen müssen was was sein
weltbild sein gesellschaftsbild ist das
ist nämlich würde des menschen ist
arbeit zu haben würde des menschen ist
das arbeit arbeitsplätze dafür
geschaffen werden würde des menschen ist
sich frei entfalten zu können würde des
menschen ist nicht zu haus zu hocken und
das geld vom staat zu nehmen und dafür
trete ich dafür kämpfe ich wir alle
müssen doch eigentlich dafür kämpfen
dass überhaupt niemand in die situation
kommt zu hause zu sitzen und harzer zu
werden ich glaube auch keiner ist harzer
und ein gernhardts rund 1 würde ich auch
noch ergänzen mich stört ein bisschen an
diesem hartz iv ist kein beruf die
versteht es im wahlkampf und der satz
ist aber die verallgemeinerung also da
steckt auch drin alle hartz 4 bemühen
sich nicht richtig sondern akzeptieren
als leben stand wir wissen wie wir
wissen ja alle dass dieses hartz4 ein
elend ist und dass gerade ein
schlamassel genannt aus dem man
möglichst auskommen möchte ich habe aber
den eindruck dass sich ein zu großer
teil der dann eingerichtet haben also
wenn sie es nicht gäbe wenn der rtl2 das
programm abschaffen also wir haben
offensichtlich eine form von von ich
will mal sagen prekariat und das muss so
aufpassen dass man nicht von oben herab
argumentiert oder dass man nicht dieses
furchtbare elitäre aber wir sind ja in
dieser sozialen erziehung groß geworden
dass man einerseits teilt andererseits
aber durch leistung etwas bietet und
durch das mit sich einrichten ja der
nächste schritt ist ja das
bedingungslose grundeinkommen wäre und
das steht im wahlprogramm der grünen
drin und das fände ich dann also
wirklich hier eine gewisse eine
respektlosigkeit gegenüber allen
leistungsträgern
wir kennen doch den wahlkampf hier
respekt der hammer muss man muss die
rentner respektieren man muss auch die
hartz4 empfänger respektieren ich sage
okay in ordnung aber man muss auch
mindestens so viel die
respektieren die was leisten und die in
das ihnen das ganzes sozialsystem
einzahlen also wer transfer geber muss
mindestens so respektiert werden wie der
transfer nehmer und ich glaube eine
gewisse wertschätzung für all diejenigen
denen das system 1 1 ist schon
angebracht das kommt viel zu wenig zum
ausdruck hier im öffentlichen diskurs
vor allem
muss dieser dieser verbindlich dieser
respekt gedanke dann immer beidseitig
sein
also in dem beruf steckt ja auch
sozusagen drin in dieser dann
pervertierte satz meine kinder sollen
mal den gleichen beruf ergreifen wie ich
das steckt er ist sozusagen auch darin
nämlich wenn jemand in hartz4 ist es ja
überliefert dass oft auch die nächste
generation in hartz4 ist und da finde
ich hat der staat schon auch eine
aufgabe diesen teufelskreis zu
durchbrechen
und jetzt sind wir wieder bei den alten
politik modellen die einen geben sich
gar nicht die mühe weil sie sagen wir
bezahlen das und wenn man sich
eingerichtet hat geht so weiter und die
anderen in dem fall asse zeigt hey wir
setzen wollen anreize setzen wir wollen
ja auch der nächsten generation anreize
setzen so dass sie sich selber befreien
kann aus diesem teufelskreis
das ist glaube ich das richtige modell
und ja da hat er einen punkt gemacht
ansonsten ist er in dem thriller richtig
vermöbelt worden was ich so leid bin es
wir reden immer darüber also geld ohne
leistung ich rede jetzt nicht manche
trends jahren dabei sind ja immer auch
außen aber was mich so stört ist keine
der parteien hat in diesem
bundestagswahlkampf mal gesagt dass viel
bildung auch für die eliten oh da ist
medizin studium psychologie studium das
trauen sich viele überhaupt nicht
aufgrund der hohen kredite anzufangen in
deutschland wenn man ein psychologie
studiert und nicht aus obwohl am familie
ist hat man am ende mindestens 50.000
euro kreditschulden am ende und muss
noch psychotherapeuten ausbildung darauf
machen die kosten circa 25.000 euro der
meister der handwerksmeister der kostet
auch geld während man chinesische kultur
umsonst an der uni studieren kann ich
meine nur damit mir kommt es immer ein
bisschen zu wenig dran ich finde es gut
mit dem hartz iv ich finde dass die
politik in diesem wahlkampf zu wenig
darüber geredet wie man das
durchlässiger machen kann mit den
kindern aufschnitt aus muss er leichter
möglich sein medizin jura und
psychologie sind für mich eliten
studiengänge das macht machen die
wenigsten die nicht aus dem bildungshaus
halt kommen und ich glaube darüber muss
man viel mehr ich hatte sowieso kann
inhaltlich geführten wahlkampf mimikry
es liege am anfang nur um personen nur
um äußerlichkeiten
ich glaube das lag auch daran weil der
wahlkampf gar nicht in der realität hat
stattfinden können also kona bedingt gab
es keine wahlkampfveranstaltung in seen
auf plätzen es war ein ein medial und im
internet abgebildet der schein wahlkampf
und deswegen wurde er auch so äußerlich
und eine äußerlichkeiten entlang geführt
und deswegen kam so wichtige
ordnungspolitischen debatten gar nicht
auf die tagesordnung
[Musik]